bonjour à tous bienvenue dans europe
hebdo nous sommes à strasbourg au
parlement européen c'est parti pour 30
minutes d'actualité européenne
dans cette émission je vous emmène à
copenhague à quelques jours de la coop
21 nous avons voulu savoir comment le
pays et comment la ville avait réussi à
lutter contre la pollution cet exemple
est-il généralisable débat ensuite avec
karima delli
mais d'abord quelques jours après les
attentats sanglants qui ont endeuillé
paris et à l'heure où bruxelles vie sous
menace terroriste nous avons été à la
rencontre de martin schulz président du
parlement européen avant de recueillir
sa parole et son analyse petit retour
sur les faits avec hugo barbier
lorsqu'un état de l'union est attaqué
les autres pays doivent lui prêter
assistance
j'ai demandé au ministre de la défense
de saisir et demain ses homologues
européens au titre de l'article 40 de 7
du traité de l'union et l'union répondu
présentes par la voix de federica mot
guérini chef de la diplomatie européenne
la france aura une aide militaire et son
budget pourra prendre en compte les
dépenses liées à la menace terroriste
ces pactes de stabilité contre pacte de
sécurité
la commission a aussi proposé de
nouvelles directives pour contrôler les
armes à feu parmi ces propositions
interdire la vente de certaines armes
semi-automatiques même désactiver le
projet d'un pnr européen est remis sur
les rails
il s'agit d'un fichier qui regroupe les
données des voyageurs en avion
bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur espère le voir adopté avant
la fin de l'année
bonsoir martin schulz bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
je voulais revenir sur les attentats qui
ont connu la ville de paris et de 5 me
ces derniers jours ce sont les pires
attentats depuis la seconde guerre
mondiale les plus meurtriers bernard
cazeneuve et manuel valls ont appelé le
parlement européen à prendre en compte
leurs demandes de pnr le passenger name
record c'est-à-dire ce fichier qui va
permettre de voir quelles passagers
passent dans les vols intra
communautaire et donc de flécher un
petit peu les possibles terroristes
c'est une demande qui avait déjà été
fait après les attentats charlie-hebdo
cas ce qu'attend le parlement européen
pour valider ce pnr nous sommes déjà
depuis des mois en train de discuter pas
seulement pnrc aussi répondu rétention
des données la protection des données
c'est ce qui pose problème c'est la
protection des données ont saccagé il ya
une croix directive protection des
données propres projets de directives
pour le transfert des données des
passagers des lignes aériennes
transatlantiques internationaux et à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne c'est
tout un paquet est différente
europol aussi sur la table nous sommes
n'ont pas négocié ce paquet est bien
compréhensible que manuel valls 1 à 15,9
font appel au parlement le parlement
normalement avec une vitesse
exceptionnelle répond à ses démons ceux
qui ont peu ce peu plus du mal de
répondre sont les états membres dans les
conseils des ministres donc lloris l'on
vous le ralentissement c'est du haut
conseil des ministres et aucun projet ce
n'est pas au ralentissement
nous sommes en train de légiférer mais
la collection des données c'est de ce
côté d'un côté de médailles l'autre
c'est comment utiliser les données quel
délai pour le retenir
et comme en échange les états membres de
l'union européenne ce qu'ils savent
entre eux oui hélas ont découvert que
les mêmes gouvernements qui font taper
pas les français mais les mecs font
appel aux par le beau et collectionner
des données entre eux mêmes ne change
pas les mêmes données dont nous sommes
dans le processus de légiférer on va
jusqu'à la fin de l'année terminée j'ai
invité hier les différents des groupes
parlementaires ici au parlement pour
discuter avec eux
les coordinateurs des groupes
parlementaires les rapporteurs et on va
j'en suis sûr jusqu'à la fin de l'année
jusqu'à la fin de l'année conclure vous
disiez à l'instant que les pays
européens ont du mal à échanger leurs
données
on voit bien qu'il ya eu des ratés au
niveau du renseignement et de l'échangé
de renseignements entre les capitales
l'italie avait il ya quelques temps
proposé une agence européenne du
renseignement est ce que vous êtes sur
cette même ligne
je ne sais pas que ça c'est la solution
si c'était la solution oui mais
peut-être on n'a pas besoin une agence
traditionnelle il ainsi les techniciens
à europol eurojust
si les états membres sont près de
fournir les institutions qui ont besoin
des données avec les données avec la
connaissance mais mon expérience avec
les services et créer ces îles sont très
secret donc là on voit bien qu'il ya un
vrai problème global vous on propose
donc un pnr européen un meilleur
contrôle des armes à feu
la systématisation du contrôle aux
frontières un renforcement en fait de
schengen pourtant dans le cadre des
attentats de paris ce sont des européens
qui se sont attaqués à des européens
l'attak a été fomentée peut-être en
syrie mais a été commise depuis la
belgique vers la france est-ce que c'est
pas un petit peu petit bras est ce que
ça ne risque pas d'être insuffisant comm
réd
pensez président les réponses sont
nécessaires mais ça ne suffit jamais ce
qu'on a besoin c'est que nous comprenons
comme vous l'avez bien mentionné que les
terroristes sont des européens et il
faut poser les questions pourquoi elles
sont devenues terroriste qu'est ce qui
se passe avec les jeunes hommes et
jeunes femmes qui se radicalise pourquoi
ça c'est à dire il ne faut pas seulement
répondre à ce défi avec des mesures de
sécurité il faut aussi analyser les
raisons qui nous connaissons tous c'est
une sorte de sentiment d'exclusion
alain côté aussi un des privilégiés
d'une situation des privilégiés pardon
des jeunes dont les banlieues et si
l'adresse dessine sur votre avenir c'est
déjà un et une exclusion en soit dans la
société donc temps des raisons pour
comprendre que les sources d'un certain
nombre de terrorisme sont chez nous même
ça ne peut pas nous empêcher de
comprendre que d'aller chez est une
force avec une brutalité volonté de tuer
son précédent vous disiez qu'il ne faut
pas avoir que des réponses sécuritaires
que pensez-vous de la mesure prise par
le gouvernement français et par françois
hollande de l'état d'urgence en france
est ce que ce n'est pas quand on est au
niveau européen et quand on est garant
des textes et des libertés fondamentales
une forme de dépassement un petit peu du
droit quand je crois pas un président de
la république dans une situation comme
il est charlie hebdo en janvier
maintenant au mois de novembre
le bataclan et les restaurants avec
confronter avec le fait qu'il y à une
bombe des terroristes qui ne vise plus
un groupe spécial où les représentants
de l'état ou de la société régulation
des populations pour intimider n'a
aucune autre possibilité que répondre
avec la fermeté qui est exprimé par
l'état d'urgence et moi je suis
absolument je le connais très bien
franchement au long de cet homme qui a
toujours défendu les valeurs
fondamentales individuelles les droits
individuels
je crois que l'état d'urgence est dans
les mains d'un homme absolument
responsable en ce qui concerne les
droits des françaises et des français
on a constaté durant l' enquête que des
passeports de réfugiés syriens auraient
été utilisés par certains terroristes
notamment ceux qui ceux qui ont fait
usage de bombes près du stade de france
à saint denis
certains pointent du coup la
responsabilité de la grèce de la turquie
et donc la possibilité pour les tirs
terroristes d'utiliser le chemin des
migrants des réfugiés pour entrer en
europe est ce que vous y croyez
non et je me fais toujours des saisons
qui ont le lendemain d'un attentat comme
celui là déjà tous les conclusions qu'il
n'y a pas selon vous de terroristes
potentiels dans les réfugiés qui
accélérera un pas après l'autre
tout d'abord vous m'avez posé cette
question sur les passeports là un moment
je reste là parce que c'est complètement
disparu
si vous regardez soigneusement les
publications personne n'en parle mais le
lendemain de l'attentât est de l'art et
de la découverte tout le monde a tout de
suite dit ah ah qu'est ce qu'il y avait
avec ce
avec ce passeport pourquoi personne n'en
parle aujourd'hui par trois raisons
premièrement les experts tout de suite
on dit c'est peut-être peut-être aussi
une une trace fraudeuse parce que le
passeport était enregistrée en grèce et
en serbie en même temps fatigué à ce
trafic les forest voilà peut-être en
faut 2 un terroriste qui s'explose lui
même et qui a son passeport avec lui la
carte d'identité donne immédiatement aux
services de sécurité le réseau auquel il
appartient alors normalement ils ne
s'exposent pas on sait s'identifiant
automatiquement ça c'était exceptionnel
3 oui il y as peut-être parmi les huit
cent mille réfugiés aussi des gens qui
étaient filtrés en infiltré mais nous
avons eu en allemagne par exemple une
centaine d'écart d'allégations où les
gens ont dit il faut regarder
aucun corps cette épreuve est donc pas
exclue mais aussi par preuves et est ce
que vous diriez comme certains ont
pointé en fait depuis ces derniers jours
que coenguen est un échec
donc je n'aime pas échec sherin a
tellement que la libre circulation de
notre marché commun et j'écoute ça les
contrôles aux frontières comme ça se
passe ici à strasbourg actuellement
entre l'allemagne et la rétablir les
contrôles aux frontières
paul la cap 21 non pas seulement ça
c'est aussi admissibles dont les cadres
de chaîne vient d exception des cas
exception exceptionnel et ce qui se
passe ce qui s'est passé à paris c'est
un cas exceptionnel mais il faut à notre
côté aussi comprendre que la libre
circulation des marchandises des
capitaux des services et des personnes
sondées 4 liberté de marché intérieur et
si vous par exemple transporter les
marchandises ou des services à
l'intérieur de l'union européenne
ça ne fonctionne pas sans la libre
circulation des personnes
moi j'habite à côté d'une frontière sur
le triangle maastricht liège aix la
chapelle l'allemagne les pays bas et la
belgique
les deux grands plus grand port en
europe
anvers et rotterdam toutes les
marchandises qui viennent de là-bas
elles sont transportées vers les 82
millions allemands qui les consomment
passe par aix la chapelle si vous fermez
là les frontières pour les citoyens et
pour les camions il dure 24 heures et à
stuttgart la production des mercedes
terminé parce que les transports c'est
just in time où les grands supermarchés
n'ont plus de marchandises donc rétabli
des conserves et touvier les cats ont
des nids des conserves ni des poissons
frais qui viennent aussi de là bas ça
veut dire quoi
on arrête vous parce que vous êtes une
personnalité avec le droit de libre
échange mais dans une voiture et avec
tes cheveux frisés des heureux des yeux
bras on vous aurait dit madame votre
passeport mais le camions transportés
par votre frère peut passer ça c'est en
europe qui dure 24 heures et les mêmes
gens qui insistent de l'arrêt
rétablissement des contrôles aux
frontières vont se révolter parce qu'ils
n'ont pas envie de passer la moitié de
leur vie dans un bouchon
je comprends bien maintenant quand ils
m'ont dit qu'il faut rétablir les
contrôles aux frontières extérieures de
l'europe c'est que on a peut-être été
trop loin dans ce manque de contrôle
quand on a des terroristes qui sont en
capacité d'aller chargé des armes en
espagne de remonter toute l'europe de
passer par la belgique et de redescendre
en france on a aussi échoué quelque part
l'extérieur sans c'est clair la
protection des frontières extérieures
c'est un des beaux arts de l'union
européenne dans les mains des états
membres
nous avons donné comme souvent une
responsabilité à l'union une tâche
communautaire protection des frontières
extérieures même pas dans les mains de
monsieur juncker de monsieur chose ou de
monsieur tout c'que
dans les mains des gouvernements grecs
ton amer du gouvernement espagnol
le gouvernement bulgare du gouvernement
polonais pour protéger les frontières
extérieures de l'union européenne et si
ça ne fonctionne pas parce que pas tous
ces gouvernements mais quelques de ce
gouvernement incapable de protéger les
frontières ou ne veulent pas
on blâme ensuite l'union alors ce qui
nous propage priorité pour les solutions
nationaux comme cette femme qui veut
devenir président de la france qui siège
ici au parlement nous raconte sa
toujours l'europe des nations tout
d'abord versé voilà l'europe des nations
que nous voyons agir dans la protection
des frontières extérieures
l'échec potentiel du contrôle aux
frontières extérieures c'est l'échec des
nations a donc garde pas l'échec des
nations c'est pas l'échec de nation
c'est l'échec d'un système erronée on ne
peut pas donner une responsabilité à une
communauté ensuite ça soumettre sous ils
réservent en permanence des prérogatives
nationales
ça ne fonctionne pas dernière question
monsieur le président la turquie a
aujourd'hui abattue en avion russe qui a
violé son espace aérien
est-ce qu'on est dans une escalade du
conflit en syrie j'espère nos parce
qu'on a besoin soit la turquie et la
russie pour battre dahesh donc que ce
que nous avons besoin pour une coalition
contre ces assassins sont maintenant
dans une telle situation
c'est lamentable j'espère beaucoup qu'on
va trouver une solution diplomatique
pour cet incident merci beaucoup
monsieur le président merci
voilà pour cet entretien exclusif avec
le président du parlement européen nous
l'émission continue direction maintenant
copenhague à quelques jours de la cap 21
la bonne élève de l'europe en matière de
lutte contre la pollution est elle un
exemple généralisable c'est ce que nous
avons voulu savoir et c'est louis
sybille qui a mené l enquête
c'est un bruit que l'on entend partout à
copenhague
tous les jours une marée humaine a
envahi les rues de la ville à vélo
ici tout est fait pour leur faciliter la
vie
350 km de pistes cyclables avec parfois
plus de trois voix et des parkings pour
vélos à la sortie du métro bien remplie
klaus bondam est un habitué de la petite
reine c'est une bonne façon de
contempler la ville j'utilise mon vélo
tous les jours
en fait je vis loin à la campagne nous
prenons une voiture avec mes collègues
jusqu'à l'entrée de la ville où les
autos rôle s'arrête et pour le reste du
trajet utilise un de mes quatre vélos
un habitant de copenhague sion 2 seront
ainsi à son travail
en comparaison paris c'est dix fois
moins qu'au sport c'est bon pour la
pollution de l'air et la pollution
sonore est excellent pour la santé
publique
ça crée aussi ce genre de ville où l'on
peut se regarder et se rencontraient pas
un regard d'avoir une ville dynamique
pour lutter contre la pollution de l'air
la ville de copenhague s'est attaqué au
coeur du problème des voitures
il reste bien quelques unes mais
beaucoup moins des zones spécifiques
sont même interdite aux véhicules
cet urbaniste a conçu des ponts
entièrement dédié au vélo pour lui
copenhague est un modèle qui peut
s'exporter facilement dans la seconde
ville au danemark nous avons beaucoup de
colline il ya encore 20 % de cyclistes
donc que toutes les excuses du type où
il fait froid il fait chaud nous avons
des collines je veux dire pendant 60 ans
le vélo a été le principal moyen de
transport et c'est de nouveau le
principal ici donc il n'y a plus d'
excuse c'est simplement la volonté
politique est d'adapter la ville aux
pratiques et nadal pas d' excuses et des
choix politiques courageux chaque année
la ville dépense 14 millions d'euros
pour construire entre autres les pistes
cyclabes copenhague peut être la
première ville neutre en carbone d'ici
un objectif ambitieux la municipalité
veut donner l'exemple avec des
infrastructures propres en voulons que
nos voitures nos bus
nos camions deviennent neutre en carbone
cette année l'une de nos principales
lignes de bus va utiliser du gaz naturel
et la majorité de nos canaux poubelles
sont au gaz naturel aujourd'hui le gaz
naturel est beaucoup moins polluant que
les autres énergies fossiles la lutte
contre la pollution de l'air se passe
aussi sous terre maintenant la
température va gripper dans ses
sous-sols
il fait 50 degrés à cause de ces tuyaux
qui fournissent le chauffage à
l'ensemble de la population de
copenhague soit plus de cinq cent mille
personnes
un réseau de 1500 km
it's like c'est comme une autoroute pour
le transport du chauffage et après nous
avons des routes locales pour la
distribution un chauffage propre
il a permis de réduire de 3 2% le nombre
de particules de carbone une bonne
partie de l'eau est chauffée grâce à la
biomasse
autrement dit ce sont les déchets
urbains qui servent de combustible au
lieu du gaz ou du pétrole et flore
locale de la cgt au ce et si vous
regardez la ville il n'y a plus de
cheminée donc la seule véritable
pollution dans les villes comme
copenhague provient du trafic routier
est pas du chauffage en aucun cas
environ 40% des déchets de la ville sont
réutilisées grâce à un système de
collecte efficace
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est 52% du
total du chauffage de l'agglomération de
copenhague qui se fait à partir
d'énergies renouvelables comme les
éoliennes
le pays est le pionnier dans ce domaine
cette énergie produit une grosse partie
de l'électricité danoise lutter contre
la pollution
c'est peut-être aussi prendre de la
hauteur chaque année plus de 5000 m² de
thouars deviennent verts à copenhague
les citoyens se sont emparés de ces
coins vers des potagers poussent un peu
partout
objectif développer les circuits courts
oui nous avons des brocolis
en fait nous avons environ 50 variétés
de légumes ici et maintenant c'est la
fin de la saison donc c'est moins vert
qu'il ya un mois à bangor
essayons de minimiser le transport de
nourriture
en fait on essaie de tisser des liens
entre le consommateur et le producteur
toutes ces infrastructures font de
copenhague
la deuxième ville d'europe la moins
polluée juste derrière zurich en suisse
un modèle même si elle aimait encore 2,5
millions de tonnes de gaz à effet de
serre alors peut-on généraliser cet
exemple de copenhague à d'autres villes
d'europe c'est la question que je vais
poser à karima delli
bonjour bonjour karima delli vous êtes
députée européenne membre du groupe des
verts vous êtes coordinatrice de la
commission transports et vous venez de
rendre un rapport qui s'appelle mobilité
urbaine durable qui a été voté en
commission et qui attend donc le 2
décembre d'être votée en séance hier
voilà quand vous voyez l'exemple de
copenhague et on voit bien 350 km de
pistes cyclables
donc là on voit bien qu'il ya quand même
eu un effort de fait 14 millions d'euros
qui ont été investi là-dedans le
chauffage urbain les toits verts est-ce
que c'est généralisable à toutes les
villes d'europe
alors oui toutes les villes devrait
tendre vers ce modèle mais sauf qu'il
faut rappeler que copenhague a fait un
choix politique important qui datent pas
de quelques années il faut vous il faut
attendre le lendemain notamment de la
crise pétrolière ou copenhague décidé de
vraiment sortir de sa dépendance au
pétrole
dès les années 70 d'égaliser soixante
dix il ya vraiment une volonté politique
de dire le pétrole il faut en sortir
donkey mise vous l'avez vu dans le vôtre
en reportage sur le chauffage urbain
il va alimenter l'ensemble de la ville
et ainsi de la mobilité douce et
notamment copenhague aujourd'hui elle se
dispute un petit peu la place avec
amsterdam comme la capitale européenne
du vélo parce que le vélo
oui c'est une industrie aussi qui crée
énormément de 2
de d'emplois mais surtout il ya une
volonté de tout de suite faire ce
nouveau modèle de ville où on s'adapte
plus aux besoins des citoyens qu'aux
besoins qui a été trop aujourd'hui
utilisée dans les années 70 jusqu'à
présent autour de la voiture donc on
change le modèle eh oui ce modèle est
possible de le mettre en oeuvre a dans
d'autres villes mais encore faut-il 2
valant de volonté politique mais surtout
de mesures très fortes et c'est ce que
porte notamment mon rapport donc moi ce
que ce qui m'intrigue c'est que on voit
bien aussi qu'il ya des fonds 1 14
million d'euros à investir en fait
chaque année pour créer ces circulations
douces pour améliorer le réseau etc
est ce que dans un contexte contraint
comme on voit aujourd'hui en termes
budgétaires on est dans la capacité de
faire ce virage est donc de permettre en
fait une vie un peu plus douces ou des
circulations plus douce à nos
concitoyens alors ça c'est revient moins
cher d'investir dans la mobilité douce
que d'avoir cette moi j'appelle de cette
mobilité subie et non choisie
aujourd'hui le fait qu'on ait une
pollution et les pics de pollution dans
les différentes villes coûte rien qu'en
termes de santé publique oui plus de 700
milliards d'euros plus qu'honnête en
milliards d'euros volé 100 milliards
d'euros- à l'europe au niveau européen
au niveau européen la pollution la
pollution la pollution c'est ce que dit
l'onu c'est la maladie du 21e siècle
parce que notre parc européen de
voitures ses 55% du diesel qu'il faut
sortir aussi de cette question du diesel
qui va être aussi un des grands débats
qu'on va avoir durant le rapport le 2
décembre
mais il faut mettre en évidence
réellement qu' il n'y a pas que la
voiture vous savez en europe 50 % des
déplacements on prend sa voiture juste
pour faire moins de 5 km et tous les
trois quarts des trois quarts des autres
déplacements se font avec la voiture
donc il faut aujourd'hui changer la
donne changer de modèle sur les modèles
ça veut pas dire non plus de pointer
ceux qui n'ont pas le choix donc il faut
faire en sorte que la mobilité de demain
ce soit un droit fondamental mais ce que
sera accessible à tout le monde
voilà le problème c'est que j'entends
bien c'est effectivement une belle idée
et on se dit pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'irait pas là dessus de demain pourquoi
pas maintenant c'est comment on finance
a alors très simplement
vous savez en europe il ya ce qu'on
appelle une taxe poids lourd alors on ne
dit pas taxe poids lourds ont dit
eurovignette et l'eurovignette une
grande partie d'un certain pourcentage
va aller dans la mobilité urbaine
durable
on a un plan qui s'appelle en latex
toile au pour l'instant par exemple en
france on n'est pas mise en oeuvre
n'allait pas encore mises en oeuvre mais
dès janvier
l'europe va légiférer sur l'eurovignette
que c'est la même chose donc la france
devra prendre en compte notamment la
taxe poids lourds dont une partie de
cette taxe qui est quand même devra être
infecté devra être affectée la mobilité
urbaine durable
on peut regretter qu'en france justement
nous sommes le 25e pays sur 28 qui n'a
pas de fiscalité écolo alors que c'est
un manque à gagner 1 la taxe poids
lourds l'écotaxe comme on dit c'est plus
d'un milliard d'euros avec 1 milliard
d'euros qui étaient fléchés sur des
projets de développement urbain durable
et on se souvient effectivement c'était
tout
nick avec la bretagne notamment et les
bonnets rouges qui avaient détruit
quelques portiques voilà donc ça c'est
juste un des outils il ya d'autres
outils énormément de ville met en place
des péages urbains on le voit ce qui se
passe à londres
une partie de ces recettes va être
affecté dans la mobilité urbaine durable
et en plus il ya le plan juncker le plan
young alors le plan de relance en fait
le 315 milliards d'euros voilà le plus
fameux plan doit être normalement
fléchés sur ossus durable et donc pour
la première fois dans ce plan nous avons
une ligne qui dit bien investissements
dans la mobilité durable
donc on a les financements même temps il
faut de la volonté politique
il faut expliquer la parfois les
certaines villes où certaines régions en
europe préfère investir sur la route que
sont les alternatives qui est une bêtise
absolue parce que un c'est à mon cas
gagner notamment en termes
d'infrastructures durables et mais se
trouve surtout c'est sur le dos de la
santé des citoyens
aujourd'hui on a que la question de la
mobilité a des conséquences terribles
sur l'urgence sanitaire parce qu'on sait
par exemple que le diesel ça va ça
provoque plus de 400
le décès prématuré en europe dont il
fait en fait anticipé vous aviez
d'ailleurs pris position sur le diesel
gate dont les constructeurs européens
qui ont trafiqué leurs véhicules de
toutes sortes en fait à ce qu'il rentre
dans les clous de la législation
européenne quelques mots là-dessus
rapidement est-ce qu'il faut s'attendre
en fait à ce que l'europe et a fortiori
les états sévisse contre ces
constructeurs
moi je trouve que c'est un véritable
scandale puisque il ya une complicité
organisé les états membres était au
courant la commission européenne était
au courant de l'ensemble de ces fraudes
on a menti aux citoyens pourquoi pas ce
qu'on leur a dit acheter ce genre de
véhicule
c'est un diesel mais les profs alors que
ce n'est pas vrai on est pas propre
troisième chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
faut du contrôle et de la transparence
c'est pour ça que nous demandons nous le
groupe des verts une véritable enquête
parlementaire pour faire toute la
lumière et la transparence sur ce qu'est
l'eau sur ces dossiers voilà merci
beaucoup karima delli vous avoir éclairé
sur cette question pour nous c'est fini
cette semaine vous retrouverez ahmed
tazir la semaine prochaine à très vite
sur les chaînes parlementaires ciao